hi everyone in this video we'll talk
about alternative splicing and the
mechanism which leads to alternative
splicing
so from human genomic project we know
that human genome has at least twenty to
twenty-five thousand genes but while
scientists try to figure out the
proteome that means total number of
proteins present in human they found out
that the number of estimated proteins to
be something around 500 thousand now
there was a popular hypothesis in the
field that one gene codes for one
protein right and the message for
production of this protein is embedded
in the DNA now if one gene is coding for
one protein then there should be 25,000
proteins in the human gene in the human
body right but instead 25,000 there were
500,000 how to explain this thing
scientists crach their head for a very
long time so there are two hypotheses
right now in our hand one gene equal to
one protein and one gene equal to many
protein now question is which of these
hypothesis is true and if we for a
moment if we try to understand that one
gene equal to many protein if we believe
that then how to achieve many different
type of proteins from one particular
gene what is the mechanism by which we
can achieve this in order to explain one
gene many protein hypothesis the
alternative splicing machinery was
discovered later on now let me tell you
something for example we have
hepatocytes nerve cell or muscle cell
all of these cells have their unique
identity unit set of functions and all
of these can be generated with the help
of differential gene expression simply
all of these cell types might have
specific set of gene expressed at a
point of time that is one way of
creating their unique function
but there is another way by which the
uniqueness can be created in these cells
and unique proteins can be synthesized
in all these tissue or cell types and
that mechanism is alternative splicing
now using the alternative splicing
machinery in a combinatorial way using
the exons different mRNAs can be
produced which could be unique to
hepatitis A or could be unique to you
nerve cell let's say this might lead to
production of unique proteins and which
have different functionality and that
what make these cell types unique and
make their functions now let us try to
understand the machinery a bit so here
is our eukaryotic gene which has introns
and exons together now we know when
transcription happens they would form
the RNA from that but it will also have
the exon and intron right eventually
the h and RNA would be processed before
even it could be totally transcribed it
would be processed by the spliceosome
machinery and there would be two
consecutive transesterification reaction
which would lead to splicing of the
intron as a form of lariat and joining
the exons together now if you don't know
this processing details you can click on
the I button to get a details of these
process how splicing work and how splice
usual machinery works but in this video
our point of discussion is how
alternative splicing works so let me
tell you or let me give you a flavor of
alternative splicing imagine we have
four eggs ons I mean they are depicted
in four different colors now these
exhausts could be selected in a
tissue-specific manner in a different
combinatorial code for example this red
yellow and green exons could be selected
and a particular transcript could be
made in other and this transcript would
give rise to a particular protein in
other case this blue red and yellow
transcript with real exons are
selected which would give rise to
another different type of protein now
from the same gene we have two different
proteins by selectively picking up the
exons right that means with alternative
splicing we can generate diversity in
terms of protein production right now
these days there are quite a lot of
machinery or quite a lot of mechanisms
are well-established by which
alternative splicing can happen so we'll
look some of them so this is the primary
transcript which has exons and introns
and let me tell you one of the possible
ways by which different diversity could
be generated for example splice user
machinery can choose different type of
combinations right now so what is the
normal but normal way of splicing here
all of these exons would be joined
together and the introns would be
spliced out that is a normal version
there could be exon skipping for example
in this case exon 2 is totally skipped
and exon 1 is joined with exon 3 there
could be intron retention instead of
cleaving the intron out or removing the
intron a portion of the intron might be
remaining enough mature transcript that
leads to total change of the open
reading frame right and that might lead
to change in the message and generation
of new kind of proteins obviously
combinatorial selection of exons is also
another way for example in one
combination exon 1 and 3 could be
selected another combination exon 1 and
2 could be selected so this is known as
alternative exon selection so all of
these are the different methods by which
alternative splicing can offer now let
me give you some examples in muscle
cells and in the muscle fibers there are
globular troponin right now globular
troponin has to kind of isoforms one is
alpha troponin and another is beta
troponin and they arise due to
alternative splicing now this is the
troponin RNA so this strip amine
immature RNA
four five exons introns
now this exons could be selectively
picked in a combinatorial fashion in
this case you can see in one case exon 3
is picked but not for in other case in
zone 4 is preferred
rather than exon 3 and this leads to
different transcript right different
message which leads to production of
alpha propylene in one site or beta
troponin in other side same example
could be obtained from sv40 virus now in
sv40 virus there is a particular antigen
known as T antigen which is important
for its virulence now this T antigen has
two major exons and in the intron there
is a stop codon now obviously different
splice sites could be selected for
splicing so in this case the five prime
splice site and the three prime splice
site if it is selected then exon one an
exon 2 would be joined together and that
total intron would be spliced but if an
alternative splice site which is present
in the exam is selected with a
combination of 3 prime splice site then
a completely different mrna would be
generated which has a portion of the
intron retained right now in the first
case a full-length t-antigen would be
produced but in the second stage nor
full-length antigen could be produced
because there is a stop codon in between
that's when the truncated product would
be produced which is known as small t
antigen or a truncated t antigen so
simply by selecting different splice
sites we can understand how diversity
could be generated at a molecular level
just like alternative splicing
there is another machinery known as
polyadenylation site choice here
different polyadenylation site which is
marked by red can be selected and this
selection could be happen in a community
real fashion which leads to totally
different product
for example in the thyroid gland the
first poly a site is selected whereas in
the brain the second polyadenylation
site is selected which leads to totally
different type of products either
calcitonin or CG RP in the brain so that
also tells us that how using different
splice sites or different but
polyadenylation / asides we can generate
diversity but about polyadenylation site
choice I have a different video now
let's talk about how alternative
splicing is regulated at a molecular
level so obviously we can imagine the
alternative splicing has regulators such
as activators of alternative splicing or
repressors so these activators and
repressors work in different fashion in
different tissues and all of these
tissues does not have these or activator
or repression repressors so they would
be very specific to tissue so let me
give you an example from neuron and hip
pata site so let's say one gene is
transcribed in the neuron and hepatocyte
in a completely different fashion now in
the neuron you have a repressor binding
site right now in this repressor binding
site a repressor can bind and which
would prevent the splicing machinery to
be recruited in the splice site that
would lead to no splicing right and
retention of these eggs are so
completely different product would be
generated in the neuron compared to the
Pato site where there is no repressor
because repression is not expressed in
this example in the hepatocyte so
repressor cannot repress it as a result
splice spicy ozone machinery is
recruited and splicing takes place so
two exons are joined and the introns are
totally removed so this is how we can
clearly understand depending upon cell
type to different product could be
generated let me give you another
example this time we are talking about
us spliceosome activator or the splicing
activator so in this case there are two
particular mrna which has a intron and
inside the intron
there is a activator binding site
mistaking it is shown as repressor in
this activator binding site activator
can bind and which would augment binding
off a splice factor or the splicing
machinery which will lead to splicing in
other hand side in the hepatocyte this
activator binding domain does not bind
to activator because activator might not
be present in the hepatocyte it is not
expressed in the hepatocyte or in
hepatocyte let's say this activator
binding motif is actually embedded
deeply or it's not inaccessible so that
is why whatever it might be the reason
it might not be used as a result this
intron is retained
right now these splice is an activator
Pro
displacing activator protein or
alternative splicing activator proteins
are known as a SAR proteins these it is
our proteins ensures that alternative
splicing occurs now they can direct the
splicing machinery to different splice
site and thereby orchestrating the
events of alternative splicing because
they could lead to different
circumstances now the presence of a cell
protein ensures that splice site would
be used or the splice site would not be
used so ASA protein has two domains our
s domain and our our M motif the RRM
motif is a RNA recognition motif we
generally binds to the mRNA whereas our
s domain is the interaction domain with
the splicing machinery right now there
is another protein which is known as H n
R and P 1 these proteins are example of
splice spliceosome repressors so these
proteins they have RNA recognition motif
very similar to our RL domain but they
don't have a sr domain so we cannot
interact with these activators rather
than they are sequestered on the DNA and
preventing the splice use of machinery
to be recruited in a proper position
that is why they hinder with the slicing
process now there is completely
different type of implications of
alternative splicing as well for example
in any case mRNA which need to be
translated has to go out of the nucleus
first and there only it can be
translated right by the ribosome sitting
on the ER membrane now in many cases
where some introns are retained the
delivery of these mRNA to the nucleus is
hampered so we see in this first case
since there is a intron retention this
particular case it would lead to
retention of these splice isoform inside
the nucleus and it would not allow it to
be translated whereas in normal
circumstances may be in a different
tissue it would be exported out of the
nucleus and a product would be generated
so in this video we had looked at quite
a lot of different aspects of
alternative splicing we looked at
several examples the mechanisms the
regulation of alternative splicing now I
want to give you a brilliant example
which happened 5 million years ago
and due to alternative splicing some
major changes happen into modern and
some major changes took place which made
us humans before 5 million years ago a
small accident took place in our genome
and this accident is just a point
mutation from C to G in a gene known as
our gap 11a this argot 11a is a small
murmuring gtps which is very similar to
a g-protein now this our gap 11a due to
this mutation produced a different
protein with a complete different
functionality known as our gap 11 B
which seems to be crucial for human
evolution actually this accident really
made us what we are today
so how does that happen
this accident lead to a different choice
of a different splice donor site in area
11 a a completely different splice donor
site was used whereas in aggregate 11 be
a different splice site was used for
splicing so the splicing machinery leads
to completely different type of product
in case of argA 11 B now argot 11 B is
selective to human not presenting other
primates such as chimpanzee or other
baboons etc but they are also present
they are present in Neanderthals
Denisovans and modern man
so this alternative splice site choice
which was a result of a accident a
mutation lead to huge impact because
this gave rise to completely different
proteins with different functionalities
now what does this new protein or gap 11
B does so our gap 11 B which was
formulated 5 million year ago which was
active in our gene active in our body
for 5 million years what it does it it
works in a pathway to regulate the
cortical volume in fact if we compared
human and chimpanzee brain human has a
very thick cortex way more number of
neurons and these are gap 11 be worked
in the stem cell ensuring they
proliferate more and they have more
capability of generating neurons and
that's why human have way way more
neurons or cortical volume than assume
Panzi probably the accident which leads
to this kind of different utility
utilizing different alternative splice
sites lead to this kind of changes which
made us human today so I hope you
enjoyed this video if you liked this
video give it a quick thumbs up and
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
and do let me know in the comment that
how you like my videos thank you guys